It's
fairly neat.
It's both the head of state and the head
of government.
And that's pretty rare.
I mean,
the head of the government,
the head,
the head of government,
we expect to fulfill a litany of duties
and we get in there and do a,
b,
c,
d,
e,
whatever.
The,
how to stay is special.
The head of state is,
is,
is ideally a reflection of our better
selves.
A heightened version of the common man
or a woman.
This person that kind of embodies all
that America should be.
And you know,
to George Bush,
to his credit,
he doesn't stint on,
on who he is.
I mean,
he puts it out there to be embraced or
rejected.
And,
um,
and that's what's so weird is that,
that the Bush administration,
this is a side point,
but
okay.
The Bush administration is visionary.
I mean,
no one can ever claim that there was
anything incremental about this
administration.
It was,
it's been a visionary administration
with terrible eyesight.